today's Friday so it's the last trading
day of the week and I want to get
directly into the business into the
chart and into the main thing so the
first thing that I've noticed today is
that we are below the 4 Hour 50ma and
you can see how we are testing it as
resistance all the time which is not a
great time because you can see how for
example Bitcoin when it goes above the 4
Hour 50ma and test their support buys
for example a long signal okay so if you
are a swing Trader and you are thinking
about longing to the right size 28 300
you have a problem and is this 4 hour
50ma so in my opinion I don't think it's
a good idea
to take any long swing positions as long
as we remain below the 4 Hour 15 okay if
we see a push up a retreat support then
yes
Target this highs here first and then
also of course the range highs otherwise
you know price can continue rolling over
and go again to the range loss okay so
that's the first thing now I don't like
how much is testing a resistance to be
honest um but for the day trader so when
I go into a lower time frame I'm going
to try to make sense of what is going on
and try to find some potential traits so
the first thing is the one hour time
frame
you can see how yesterday London dropped
and then New York reversed okay we're
going to the 50 minutes time frame you
can see how the first thing I need your
date as as soon as you opened at two
o'clock you this time you can see the
candle okay that's a reversal candle he
reverses
okay he almost went to the 50ma bo it
dropped consolidate and at the end you
know we see some consolidation so it
wasn't a full retracement of the whole
drop during the London session okay it
was kind of like a half retrace so it
was only kind of like a scalp uh it was
maybe like a
250 dollars trade not much just a scalp
and since then the price action has been
awful look at this
there is no multi-trade here as you can
see all right so
what potential trades can we find today
one
I've been charting for a while and the
only thing that I came up with is the
weeks
15 minutes time frame you have here a
quick to the downside okay 26 468.
that's a week of Interest
ice price when I come to this week
I think it's going to fill it to an hour
later okay also you have here a large
green candle which is basically a liquid
pool
and you can see that it hasn't been
fully fully retraced okay
that would be your liquidy pool so
doesn't that price is still going to
visit this this Zone
I think yes because you have a week and
most weeks get the retrace
and also you have a liquidity pool uh
still there all right so that's the
first thing that I noticed in the chart
and now if you go into the one hour time
frame notice here that you have
another week in the one hour time frame
okay now if price what time is it
quarter to one okay we still have an
hour and a half before New York opens so
my plan for today is to try to take a
scalp
okay
um basically I'm looking something
similar to this week to week what it
means is
and this means that if price pumps right
at the start of the New York session
towards this week retrace the week test
the one or 50 Mas resistance and then it
drops
that's the scenario that I want to get
in for a short scalp okay and I'm going
to Target this uh wig over here so that
would be around 300 uh trade okay no but
for this kind of price action week to
week that's all I'm looking for also if
you notice the 150 Main and the week are
pretty much in the same level I would
say but also if you go to the four hour
time frame
you want to see
that Candlestick in the four hour time
frame if you actually see a pump towards
that way on the on the 1r50 May it's
very important that if you want to take
a short
the four hour Candlestick has to close
below the 4r50ma
because if it doesn't and that candle
clue is about the 4r50 main
tune you are still bullish in this time
frame and this time frame is you know
higher time from that one of your domain
and therefore it has more strength so
um that's something that I want to that
I want you guys to to keep in mind what
I'm trading today is
keeping an eye on the four hour time
frame just in case that week that
Candlestick closes above the 50ma and
the four or something because if it does
that trade is invalidated okay because
then you could do a resistance support
flip so what it was resistance then
could be support
and that's when I tell you price is set
to for example retrace this liquid pool
over here okay you see that candle so
that's what I mean guys
um I don't think we're gonna see much
much going on
and I think that are the best
something like this is what the market
might deliver today okay so remember
what I'm looking for no Financial advice
this could be completely wrong and then
I might get stopped but what I'm looking
for today is I push up right at the
start of the New York session to fail
this week in the one hour time frame
which is Confluence with the 50ma then I
want this to be tested resistance to get
rejected and go for the other week in
the 15 minutes time frame okay all of
this while in the four raw time frame we
managed to continue closing that for our
candle below the 50ma okay because this
candle you open at 12 UTC time only 45
minutes ago it closes then at four
o'clock okay only one hour two hours
after the New York session starts
so that is a trait that's what I want to
see I push up one hour time frame fill
that week test the 1 hour 50 minutes
resistance and then by four o'clock I
want this Candlestick if the previous
devices happened
I want this candle to close again below
the 50ma if that happens then I'm gonna
have a high conviction
the we are gonna get all the way down to
this week okay and this is pretty much
uh one percent trade with some leverage
could be turned out to a five percent
trade with for example times five level
eight which is not much okay so that is
pretty much everything that I'm looking
for today regarding price action now it
wouldn't surprise me if we see the drop
straight away
okay because in the four hour time frame
it's not looking good we have tested so
many candles the 15 minutes resistance
so I'm not February Longs today I think
it's pretty clear that I'm favoring
shorts as long as we remain below the 4
Hour 50ma it's as simple as that get me
Above This level
get me above the 4r50 main and then I'll
talk about this week here sorry about
this liquidity pool here for example
okay
that's that's what's going to happen
then I'll talk about these highs and
then I'll talk about the rain size but
for now
the upside is very limited as long as we
are below the four or 50 minutes so I
hope that was clear guys now please let
me take you to high block Capital let's
check what is going on there
first things first guys liquidation
levels do you know the rule first
liquidation levels then hit map
so you can see how the Delta is showing
that five to four billion dollars
worth of show liquidations are at risk
now the question is is that a big enough
amount or are they going to try to
increase that position to who knows 7 8
10 billion dollars before the reversal
okay
also for this chart is at the
liquidations are to the upside check out
all these spikes at the right of the
chart they are to the upside okay to the
downside you don't have many so the
liquidations is clearly to the upside
which it's um I would say it contradicts
the chart because one below the 4r50ma
but that's what I mean
if we can flip that 4.50 main to support
then we're gonna come and clear all
these liquidations quite quickly I would
say all right otherwise they can't wait
it's as simple as that now let's go to
the liquidation hit map
like what do we have here
I want to check first 12 hours time
frame
let me see what we got here
okay it's nothing really uh not much
going on
not much going on uh pretty uh gray so
um nothing really going on there now so
in this time frame
here you can see more activity because
you can see how we are right between two
liquidation zones you have 27 600 and
then to the downside you have 26 100 so
the question is which zone are they
gonna take out the next that's the
question okay are they gonna go for 26.1
k or
27.6k uh that's the main question about
however
I think that it's not gonna happen today
I have that feeling okay I think that
it's it's likely that they continue
building the Liquidations in this one
over the weekend
and then next week is that we can see a
move into this zone or 26k uh that's
pretty much what I'm saying here now one
more time frame
I'm sure we're gonna assist the loose
Liquidators are 28k
where they are and it's quite tasty to
be honest they're quite tasty and these
are lines together also with the
recognition levels this chart is clearly
telling you the liquidation the one
month time frame is to the upside so
clean the 4r50 main
and we get there okay to the range highs
on the three months time frame to see
that the liquidation is clearly to the
downside so how do you make sense of
this if the one month time frame is
telling you that the liquidation is to
the upside and three months time for me
selling the liquidations are to the
downside well you know you're still
inside the range so why not why couldn't
we take the rain size first inside the
range
go to the range size take all the
liquidity
and then as a three months time frame is
a higher time frame than the Walmart
time frame so it means that this can
take longer to develop
once you get to the Rain size you're
still inside the range you have been
broken out
now if you break out from the rains that
that's a different the story of boo if
you go to the Rain size do the deviation
or you get reacted why not why couldn't
we go to the range lows break it below
it and hit these liquidations
that's what I'm trying to make sense of
the liquidation hit maps in the one
month time frame and the three months
time frame okay it's possible that if we
clear the 4 out of 50 mate
do you know serious possibilities of
going to the right size 28k and then
we're gonna see that if you can get
rejection or a deviation and we're going
to look for the midterm this one here
are 23 400. that's all I'm saying guys
no more tomorrow right so anyway I want
to wrap this up here I don't want to
make it any longer because it's Friday
you've been listening to me all week so
rest your ears and enjoy your weekend so
next week we can have the batteries
charged and we can continue making money
right so thank you so much for watching
guys and I'll see you soon